de l'autre côté de ce léger rideau
d'acier s'étendent les pays-bas 33 mille
kilomètres carrés d'une terre indécise
et perpétuellement contesté par lundi
soluble conjuration de la vague et des
vents peu à peu soutirer à la mer qui
deux fois par jour cherche à la
reprendre aux hommes par tous les moyens
conjuguées de l'assaut brutal du siège
de la mine et de l'infiltration
m
e
je
à
pour s'établir le hollandais la
dépouiller personnes il a élu domicile
on ne sait trop quand dans un pays qui
n'existait pas il a puisé sa terre au
fond des eaux pour l'aménager au soleil
et la voici de rhuys lente et des salles
et qui lui rend grâce en multipliant ses
dons nourricier donnant naissance un
peuple amphibie qui ajoute à tous les
moyens de propulsion connu une technique
d'échassiers unijambiste appropriée à la
nature ambiguë du terrain il que dans un
instant nous verrons à l'oeuvre
en décidant la hollande la nature et
l'histoire ont dessiné aussi le landais
dont le caractère résulte directement de
la situation exposée qu'il occupe au ras
des flots il est actif comme le veut la
configuration d'un pays à défendre jour
après jour contre la menace sans cesse
recommencée de la mer qui grande au bout
du jardin
il est équilibré comme il faut bien
l'être quand on vit à la fois sur terre
et sur mer sans trop savoir si l'on
appartient à l'une ou à l'autre il est
placide et pacifique comme le sont la
plupart des peuples que le sort met aux
prises avec une telle somme de
difficultés naturelles que l'esprit de
coopération et de solidarité est la
moindre des cotisations requises par la
prudence contre l'adversité
en venant au monde
l'hollandais sait déjà qu'un seul
instant d'inattention du côté de la
barrière des eaux suffirait à noyer la
moitié de son pays
mais comment devient ton hollandais
l'histoire répond que ce n'est pas
facile il y à un million d'années aux
environs cette région du monde encore
informent évident n'était qu'un vague
bas-fonds du lieu-dit depuis mer du nord
puis vint le grand froid qui saisit
toute chose dans ses griffes de glace et
ce fut le silence
après des alternatives de froid et de
réchauffement illustrait ici et au cours
desquelles la terre accouchait
d'elle-même dans la douleur il
craquements géologiques les glaces
retirèrent et la hollande a paru
sillonné de moraine pour disparaître
encore une fois sous la mer et la glace
ouais
cette histoire c'est l'italie wru vert
sur le sol de la hollande
enfin dégagée au début de notre ère par
un effondrement marin qui fournit une
première ébauche des comptes
néerlandaise tels que nous les
connaissons
c'est la fin des grands bouleversements
la distribution des terres et des rôles
et tâches et la mère ne sait pas encore
le sien part que ses hésitations et ses
reprises de souffle se traduisent par
autant d' immense catastrophe
tantôt à la porte de la terre à la terre
est tantôt elle envahit été détruit son
ouvrage
entre temps un nouveau personnage est
survenue que nous appelons l'homme et
qui dès son entrée en scène s'emploie à
corriger le destin en imposant avec ses
pauvres en mains nues un minimum de
discipline aux forces qui l'environnent
et qu'il dépasse d'abord il élèvera pour
se mettre au sec et ouvrir un
commencement de canalisation au marais
qui reviennent continuellement lui
proposer la noyade et l'absorption dans
le grand tout des profondeurs de petit
tertre parfois reliés entre eux dont il
subsiste encore aujourd'hui de
nombreuses traces en hollande
c'est là dessus juchée sur ses faibles
hauteurs artificielle qui lui servait de
refuge et de piédestal que le batave des
premiers âges a fait ses débuts la mère
lui procure sa subsistance et assure en
outre sa protection contre les autres
animaux à deux pattes et sans plumes qui
est ré travers l'europe de terre ferme
elle pousse même la complaisance jusqu'à
édifié sur ses arrières avec l'aide du
vent une longue arrête de dunes qui lui
fournira avec la possibilité de
descendre de temps en temps de son
piédestal un supplément de sol à
cultiver mais elle n'est pas encore à
vrai dire elle ne sera jamais une amie
très sûr elle s'engouffre par la moindre
brèche de la muraille de simples et
revient ravagé ce qu'elle avait laissé
construire pendant des siècles la
hollande dresse un pays instable sujette
aux désastres une combinaison d'éléments
liquides et solides que toute la
difficulté consiste à départager
et
pline l'ancien à la queue des légions
romaines en marche vers le nord se
déclare est incapable de lire si le sol
un certain qu'il foulait d'un pied
prudent appartenait à la mer ou à la
terre hésitation juridique de pure forme
en un temps où le sol quel qu'il fût
appartenait à rome on ne sait évidemment
pas quand a commencé les normes
entreprise de refoulement des eaux qui a
permis aux landais de prendre pied sur
leur propre pays
tout ce que l'on peut dire avec le
principe est resté le même si la
technique a changé il consistait à
relier quelques émergence entre elles
par une digue de terre battue l approche
de la marée ont fermé les écluses à
marée basse on laisser s'écouler les
surplus la mer avec obligeant
s'accumulaient celi monde l'autre côté
de la digue et de nouvelles terres se
formait peu à peu que l'on ceinturait
d'un nouveau rempart ainsi naquirent
l'épaule dès qu'ils ont donné à la
hollande d'aspe géométriques que l'on
retrouve aujourd'hui sans surprise dans
la peinture abstraite de mondrian mais
la forteresse était fragile et les
hommes encore plus toutes leurs petites
affaires et leurs grandes querelles il
négligeait la surveillance de leurs
murailles de terre pour extraire la
tourbe dont il tirait à la fois saine et
combustible il creuser dans le sol mal
fixé des trous aussitôt rempli par le
flux la mer avec des alliés involontaire
dans la place le jour de la toussaint
1287 elle livre à l'assaut des fonds
sans les digues et noyant des milliers
d'êtres humains l'inondation et andy
temps d'une nuit sur la terre effrayer
le lac immense du zuiderzee deux siècles
plus tard un nouveau déluge horizontale
rayé de la carte 65 villages dans les
vestiges apparaissent ou disparaissent
tour à tour sous le voile des eaux
la mère avait vaincu si tout était à
reprend tout était à refaire
c'est alors que m légataire eu l'idée du
moulin il ne suffisait pas de protéger
les terres contre le mouvement des
marées il fallait encore les assécher
pour les consolider
être légataire imagina de multiplier les
moulins sur le territoire de la hollande
il réussit à convaincre les marchands
enrichi de réinvestir dans le vent des
moules les florin que leur rapporte elle
vend du commerce maritime
il obtint gain de cause les marchands un
surcroît trois filles dont le peuple
retira quelques fruits l'idée de mettre
les vater philippaerts un banquet comme
beaucoup de grandes idées et la hollande
20 ce paysage des doublés qui flottent
et qui tournoi où l'on dirait parfois
qu'un don quichotte invisible passe en
revue son ancienne arme est versé dans
l'hydraulique des lacs gigantesque
furent rendus à la culture
il
et
mais c'est seulement en 1850 à
l'ouverture de l'ère industrielle que la
bataille du hollandais pour assurer ses
pieds sur la terre de son choix pris une
tournure décisive
tandis que sur les mers la marine à
voile aller vers son déclin sur terre la
machine à vapeur remplaçait le moulin ou
en tout cas lui insuffler une énergie
indifférente aux circonstances
météorologiques un nouvel engin de
combat faisait à peu près en même temps
son apparition sur le terrain la drague
leur puissance décuplée par le génie
moderne permettait aux hommes de
légiférer sur les éléments semaine des
levées ou d'abaisser le niveau des eaux
de leur imposer des emplois pacifique
la mère allait reculer à la fin du
siècle dernier et au début celui ci elle
avait perdu une bataille mais elle
n'avait pas perdu la guerre
sympa
jack campbell
la ligue 1
you
geo
au total 31 octobre a remercié en vente
d'armes à 26 ans il ya trente ans
là
où est il
avant et
m